well let's just uh jump to the first
story and we'll uh we'll talk about
john kerry reveals biden's devotion to
radical great reset movement
from the hill this to me is really funny
because they say the great race is a
conspiracy theory but it's
actually what they've been calling it
for some time the hill says
in june elites at an important at
important international institutions
such as the world economic forum
and the united nations launched a
far-reaching campaign to reset the
global economy
the plan involves dramatically
increasing the power of government
through expansive new social programs
like the green new deal and using vast
regulatory schemes and government
programs
to coerce corporations into supporting
left-wing causes obviously this is
uh i think it's a it's a biased view of
what they're saying
but to be fair the world academic forum
has pushed a lot of left-wing causes as
they reference the great reset
it goes on to say the two justifications
for the proposal
which has been aptly named by its
supporters the great reset are the
covet-19 pandemic the short-term
justification and the so-called climate
crisis claused caused by global warming
the long-term justification
according to the great reset supporters
the plan would fundamentally transform
much of society
as world economic forum head klaus
schwab wrote back in june quote the
world must act jointly and swiftly to
revamp all
aspects of our societies and economies
from education to social contracts and
working conditions
every country from the united states to
china must participate and every
industry from oil and gas to tech
must be transformed in short we need a
great reset
of capitalism they're going to say
internationally the great reset has
already been backed by influential
leaders
activists academics and institutions in
addition to the world economic forum
and the united nations the great reset
movement counts among its international
uh among its there's a missing word i
suppose
the international monetary fund heads of
state greenpeace and ceos and resident
presidents of large corporations
and financial institutions such as
microsoft and mastercard
but in america most policymakers
including president-elect joe biden have
been relatively quiet about the great
reset
leaving many to speculate what a biden
administration would do to support or
oppose this radical plan
they go on to say that at a panel
discussion about the great reset hosted
by the world economic forum in
mid-november
former secretary of state john kerry
biden's would-be special presidential
envoy for climate
firmly declared that the biden
administration will support the great
reset
and that the great reset quote will
happen with greater speed and with
greater intensity
than a lot of people might imagine when
asked by panel host george brent
whether the world economic forum and
other and other great recent supporters
are expecting too much too soon from the
new president
or is he going to deliver the first day
on this
on these topics kerry responded the
answer to your question is
no you're not expecting too much and yes
the great reset will happen
and i think it will happen with greater
speed and with greater intensity
than a lot of people might imagine in
fact the citizens of the united states
have just done a great reset
we've done a great reset and it was a
record level of voting
kerry later argued that the great reset
is necessary to slow the climate crisis
and that quote i know joe biden believes
it's not enough to just rejoin the para
paris climate accords for the united
states it's not enough for us
to just do the minimum of what paris
requires
so i'm not going to read literally every
you know the last bit of this it's
clearly an opinion piece but it's
talking about something that's
actually happening lockdowns
i'm going to ask you destiny your
opinion because you're mentioning before
that you're for them
well oh we can check with a great reset
we're going to talk about lockdowns well
we're going to talk about the great set
for sure
i mean unless you want to respond to
that first oh that all sounded really
cool
i guess um the idea that uh we have an
opportunity to reorganize things based
around like some kind of like ongoing
crisis that might expose
uh you know weak parts of our economy or
weak parts of you know healthcare
infrastructure whatever like i think the
idea of
capitalizing on those types of disasters
and
moving new programs forward i think is
really good i think it's like pretty
standard business practice too
right like nobody files bankruptcy and
comes back the exact same way right
usually it's an opportunity to
restructure your business to get rid of
stuff that doesn't work to
improve on stuff that does work like i
don't i don't see the horrible part
about that but
more specifically lockdowns there yeah
so the i guess the general idea is that
when they're talking about lockdowns
they're not talking about covet they're
talking about the great reset and
climate change and that's that's the
gist of what i get from
john kerry's statements initially they
said the great reset you know of global
capitalism whatever would be due to
due to covet it's a great opportunity to
do it but then clearly what their real
concern is
climate change i just because you
take an opportunity to um so i think it
was chicago i think was one of the
cities that had like massive fires that
like ravaged the city and they used the
opportunity to rebuild a lot of the
city's infrastructure
i don't think people were ever claiming
they set the fires just to rebuild the
city i don't i don't think um
i don't think anybody would claim that
we want to lock down the country just to
further climate change
there might be a way to make a stop
climate change or to further climate
change anticlimactic engineering yeah um
that might be an argument that one could
make in another world where we aren't
topping ourselves every single day with
record numbers of infections and deaths
like if we were australia or
uh new zealand and we were doing
lockdowns continually then maybe like oh
hold on there's an agenda here
um but i mean like we're losing twin
towers worth of people every day
the idea that this is just a conspiracy
to pass climate change agenda stuff
it seems like a hard sell to me i don't
think it's that it's a conspiracy i
think it's that they're exploiting a
crisis
i think that's good shouldn't we do that
not necessarily
isn't it isn't a crisis like one of your
best opportunities to like restructure
like
like i give with the example of like a
like a failing business like if
something really horrible happens
generally horrible things happen because
they expose some type of flaw or defect
in what you do like isn't that the time
for change especially because that's
when you're going to get the most like
activism behind it don't people have
rights though
like don't you have a right to make
choices for yourself live your life
especially with the with the
constitution so
that's a very vague sense i mean like do
i have the right to go out and get drunk
and drive
you don't okay so we have some rights
right yes
we're not infringing on the rights of
others so whether that's crashing in a
drunk driving accident or infecting
somebody with starscope 2 right it's
probably
depends on what right we're talking
about i would imagine yeah so if
you don't want to get sick then
shouldn't you
stay home if you don't want a drunk
driver to hit you should you just never
drive well that's different that's
someone someone who might be sick and
doesn't know and is living their life
under emergency circumstances like i
have to make money and feed my family
there's no circumstance where you have
to be drunk and drive if there's no
circumstance we have to be outside and
standing right next to people without a
mask or whatever
we're not talking about that we're
talking well i mean if you want to
criticize the black lives matter
protests
and you know the the biden's you know
the big biden rallies or whatever they
just did when biden won
then yeah there's no reason for those
people to be doing that stuff you know
you can simultaneously criticize them
and the anti-lockdown people too as well
right that's not like
like i can criticize both to be to my
knowledge a lot of the people were in
those protests were wearing masks though
i mean from what i said well in the in
the biden one they were taking their
masks off and drinking and sharing
drinks was like one of the big videos
that came around
that's pretty dumb that's pretty dumb
for sure for sure but i'm just more
fundamentally i'm just saying that like
um
the to come up with the like don't we
have rights well yeah i mean of course
we do
but i mean we learned this growing up
with more rights also comes more
responsibility you know like so
yeah i think that the drunk driving
thing doesn't work
like there's a guy in staten island
which got arrested trying to run his bar
he has to
otherwise he becomes homeless and he
can't feed his family and then what do
they beg the government for help the
government's not giving it to him and
you can blame mitch mcdonnell or nancy
pelosi no we could blame mitch mcconnell
pelosi sent him
like trillions of dollars of bills were
dying on his desk but we still had we
saw a democrat saying it was pelosi's
fault you had wolf blitzer criticizing
policy so i think it's fair to point the
finger at both they
i we we can we're pointing a very short
dwarven finger at one and we're pointing
like the
the nose of pinocchio at the other um in
terms of people fighting over
specifically you know what is pelosi
pushing for what is she not pushing for
um there can be back and forth over that
the fact of the matter is there was some
like 2.5 trillion dollar bill that was
left in mcconnell's desk when he moon
walked out of the senate after they
confirmed acb
so i mean like the blame is not even
remotely close to equal there
the house passed legislation the senate
let it die that's true you can't you
can't both sides that one i don't think
but
well i think that's whether or not it's
me trying to do it i'm this is what
people are doing
right well so wolf blitzer might have
specifically criticized like hey pelosi
he stated what he cited rokana he was
citing democrats who were calling out
pelosi
and pelosi didn't want to answer the
question so
look if like obviously if you're on the
right the right's gonna say see
the issue with the heroes act was that
they wanted fun like you know they were
stuffing things in it that didn't make
sense and the republicans did the same
thing they wanted money for an fbi
building
i don't want i don't want to go off on
the on the you know democrat first
republican
well it's important because i don't
obviously it's a huge die hard biden fan
uh i'm going to fight viciously back
against idea that both sides messed up
the fact of the matter is
that if i go into the senate um they did
not give us legislation for any type of
coronavirus release and pelosi did she
delivered we have that legislation it's
sitting on the floor of the
senate and it's never going to be called
for a vote well so i want i want to keep
it to
yeah the lockdown rights the great reset
stuff yeah
so the government is clearly not
providing for people
regardless regardless of whose fault it
is you can say it's republicans fault
then absolutely sure
what is a working-class you know man or
woman to do
when they're told and specifically in
staten island the issue was that
this bar wasn't allowed to serve people
but two blocks away
everything was normal they said this
specific zone has been locked down
so when the guy said i have nothing left
i have nothing left to lose
the money that did go out overwhelmingly
went to massive corporations
the lockdown is overwhelmingly uh um uh
overwhelming overwhelmingly benefiting
the money should go to massive
corporations right
no why not it should go to the people
who can then buy resources to go to the
businesses to make sure they can cover
their costs and their taxes
okay so the ppp loans uh yeah i wish i
could remember what every we're staying
for
but the ppp loans were loans given to
corporations that allow them to cover up
to 2.5 months of employment expenses
right when they paid employees if they
did that then the loan was going to be
forgiven we still haven't gotten the
paperwork for what that forgiveness
looks like but that's the point so if i
have one corporation that hires
10 000 people and another company that
hires 10 people well of course more
money's gonna go to the corporation
because there's more role to cover right
but it's not but the corporations it's a
semantic issue
it's not submitted no no that's
important yeah what i meant was not that
a small business with 10 employees
was getting money what i meant was when
the lockdown happens
the money ends up in the hands of the
ultra wealthy the stores that are
allowed to remain open tend to be the
big box stores and that's why we saw the
massive profits the massive uh
spiking and stock value for these big
companies notably amazon
the working-class people got 1200 bucks
yeah
but if you if you i'm just talking very
specifically um because it's very
important
to understand each of these policies so
the ppp only works for you
if you pay out employees so i got a ppp
loan the way that that works the way the
paperwork details is that when i get
that money i can claim up to two and a
half times the expenses of all of my
employees
and the only money that's forgiven for
me is what i pay out to my employees so
for me personally there were like two
people that i kept on payroll just
because oh well the government's gonna
pay for it yeah screw it i'll take the
ppp money and i'll continue to pay out
because it'll be forgiven i only kept
those two people
on payroll because the government gave
me that ppp money any corporation isn't
going to pocket the money it gets paid
out to employees
did they give you money to pay your rent
pay your taxes pay your costs replace
perishable goods
no it's just to cover the cost of
employing the employees so discover
everything yeah what happens to the
lockdown is
massive businesses the likes of
mcdonald's starbucks they can shut down
and they can roll
and they can observe oh 100 small
businesses are being destroyed
so that's the question i said don't
people have rights when the when these
people we've see we see now there's a
west michigan story going viral
where a guy there's a news report going
on a guy walks out of his restaurant
and he yells to the the news reporter
he's like is this you you're talking
about me
and he said they've taken everything the
money is going to the
their friends it's going to special
interests these the bail that came out
people did get a stimulus and then money
did go to small businesses
but if the small businesses are shut
down it can't sell things what happens
the restaurant their perishable goods
gone they can't reopen
so in new jersey a third of small
businesses have been destroyed sure
and i've heard similar in new york
restaurants and everything like a lot of
places that are closing are never coming
back probably so try it's a tragedy of
course yeah
so in i guess to keep it in context of
the great reset
talking about exploiting a crisis to
make some change
is also destroying the lives of people
resulting in spikes in suicide spikes in
crime
i don't think we're locking down though
for the great reset i think we're
locking down because record numbers of
people getting infected and dying from
the coronavirus if we can do something
on the backs of that
i don't think that would be the worst
thing in the world maybe part of that
great reset
and i'm almost positive without knowing
the intricacies i'm pretty sure that
part of that great reset is probably
going to be like
more stimulus for small business owners
is going to be covering health care for
people it's going to be more types of
like
checks or disbursements during like
times of crisis that's probably going to
be baked into that great reset as well
because as you
accurately pointed out the the relief
that we got so far even the ppp loans
were a joke and
what is that one twelve hundred dollar
check i think went out to every american
yep that's like
it would have almost been better to send
nothing because that's 200 i was like a
slap on the face like what's wrong do
you know that 23.6
of all us dollars ever created was
created this year um i was not aware of
that that's crazy right
that's good now too crazy it sounds like
probably the fed is doing what it can to
um the fed's primary job is to reduce
inflation and to curb unemployment
uh which is funny because trump always
takes credit for low black unemployment
even though that's squarely in the job
of the federal reserve which has no
oversight from the president
but the federal reserve probably sees
that we are spiking unemployment as long
as we're not raising in inflation which
we haven't been
their goal would probably be some form
of qe quantitative easing or super low
interest rates whatever so yeah that
makes sense
i think first of all i'd say i agree
with you on a lot of these things
and also if you if your perspective is
the lockdowns are strictly because of we
have as pandemic
that's an opinion i guess you know you
can you'll argue that you're correct
i think when you look at certain
jurisdictions and you look at the world
health organization
saying it's a very very last resort it
should be avoided and it can be
and they do it anyway it sounds to me
like well
they've said it they want to exploit
covet 19 it's their opportunity to enact
this policy
and they they didn't say it was because
of kova 19 they said it was because of
climate change
so do you know should i just disregard
the world health organizations
warning about lockdown i don't know
among major countries because i know
there are some smallers but among every
country we're 11th right now and per
capita death and we lead the world in
absolute death i don't know what last
resort sounds like to you but that
sounds like we're pretty close to like
last resort there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you